Okay, so now that we have seen two types of dependencies and
how can they affect the scheduling of instructions in a processor just trying to
do more than an instruction per cycle, let's do a dependency quiz.
Let's say we have a processor with a classical five-stage pipeline,
meaning that in one cycle it fetches, then reads registers and
decodes, then executes, then performs a memory access and finally,
writes registers. Let's also say that the processor has forwarding that can,
if the result has been produced, it's going to feed it to the instruction
correctly even though maybe the result has not been written to a register yet.
But the result has to have been produced, meaning that the instruction that
produces the result had to either finish the execute stage if the result is
something like a plus or had to finish the memory stage if this is a load
instruction. So, we can basically then fit that result to the instruction that
executes in the next cycle without having to wait for the producing instruction
to get to the right register stage, just as we discussed before. And finally,
let's say that this processor can execute ten instructions in each stage. So,
theoretically it could in one cycle fetch ten instructions, then decode all ten,
then execute all ten if there are no dependencies, and so on.
So, in five cycles it's going to execute all ten instructions.
If we have 20 instructions, the first ten would be fetched in the first cycle.
It would immediately in the next cycle fetch the ten. So
theoretically, it would be able to finish all 20 in six cycles because we still
have to get to the right reg stage. The question is, when do we execute and
write back each of these instructions? So we have these six instructions and
the question is when do we execute them. To help you get started, let's say
that the very first cycle is cycle zero, so that is when we fetch them all.
It reads registers in cycle one, so it will execute definitely in cycle two.
Also, because the ADD here is using R2, it has to wait for
the MUL to execute and then forwarding will produce MUL's value to the ADD. So
the ADD has to wait and execute in cycle three. If you look at the MUL because
it has executed in cycle two, it will go through the MEM stage in cycle three
and write its result in cycle four. The questions is, when are these others and
what cycles are they producing and writing the results?